i don't understand how that thing's
still going i heard that somebody said
they were going to put it all right
they're still taking it
everybody here hey brooke hello
uh
welcome welcome uh to another exciting
episode
of
when is america gonna start acting like
the great country we keep telling
ourselves we are
you remember we were here a year ago
after a 15
year battle
to get congress to recognize that the
first responders
on 9 11 were sick and dying
and needed health care
and and disability and john feel the
feel good foundation and all the the
first responders and survivors and
victims came down to washington over and
over and over again
sick and dying walking the halls of
congress just to get them to recognize
the basic humanity of what they were
dealing with that their selflessness and
heroism
had put them in harm's way
and they had been sick
and when it was done
we thought it was done
but it turns out
that the war fighters
that were sent to prosecute the battle
based on the attack of 9 11
now suffer
the same
injuries and illnesses that the first
responders
suffered from
and they're getting the same cold
shoulder
from congress
that they received
and so the fight starts again
the only difference between the first
responders at ground zero who are sick
and dying from toxic exposure
is that that was caused by a terrorist
attack on our country
the veterans in iraq and afghanistan
are suffering the same illnesses and the
same toxic exposure
because of the actions of our own
government
we dug burn pits
some of them 10 acres
they burned 24 7. everything every
hazardous waste was piled into them
and what's the common uh
ingredient
jet fuel jet fuel as the accelerant at
ground zero jet fuel as the accelerant
in these burn pits and so our veterans
lived 24 hours a day seven days a week
next to
toxic smoke dioxins everything and now
they're being told hey man is that stuff
bad for you i don't know we don't have
the science it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] it's about money
and we're here today to say we're not
gonna let this happen in the dark we're
going to make sure that every one of
those people goes on record
and is held accountable
for the illnesses of our veterans
hundreds of thousands of them
and they come home and they're left to
advocate on their own
and it's unacceptable
so
today we're gonna talk to uh uh some
people who've been personally affected
but i beg of you we need your help in
this
you can amplify their voices you can
make sure and we understand listen
everybody's got an awful lot on their
plate right now
but their voices deserve to be heard
their stories deserve to be heard and
their uh illnesses deserve to be treated
so i'm going to introduce to you uh
we weren't going to get involved we met
a woman named rosie torres who runs an
organization named burn pit 360. she's
not a superhero she's just a a woman
whose husband leroy torres is a captain
in the united states army he's a texas
state policeman he suffered illnesses
due to toxic burn pit exposure and his
life's been ruined
because of it and he has no
ability to get recompense because
the government has decided that the
contractors that dug the burn pits get
sovereign immunity
so leroy torres was put on trial as a
defendant for his own health
and kellogg brown and root that made 40
billion dollars in the 10 years
that they were running these burn pits
gets off scot-free
so uh she's really been the driving
force behind this she's an incredible
powerhouse her and her husband are the
best and i'm going to turn it over to
her and you'll hear some other stories
as well rosie thank you john
thank you i just want to thank the
members of congress congressman ruiz
senator gillibrand
all of your staff all of our volunteers
and all the veterans organizations that
are here
it's supporting
so john said it best at a congressional
testimony years ago that it took
responders five seconds to respond
i feel like that's the amount of time
that john and john took to respond to
are asked
to give us some hope right it didn't
they didn't hesitate at all uh to say
yes and so we're grateful for that uh
we're not here to reinvent the wheel
we're here to take the blueprint that
the 911 families created
and and apply it to our cause
so it's been over a decade uh that we've
been walking the hills of congress
only to be told to go build systemic
momentum well here we are today and this
is our systemic momentum
um i also want to say that it's been a
decade of collecting names in our
registry of those sick and dying and
many of those uh are not here anymore to
see this day
my husband couldn't travel uh to be here
with me you know he suffers from a brain
injury a lung disease so i'm just going
to read his statement for him
my name is retired captain leroy torres
and his photo's here do you want to
bring it up here okay
i served a dual role as a texas state
trooper for 14 years and a united states
army soldier for 23 years i was deployed
to bilateral iraq from 2007 to 2008
where i was exposed to chemicals from
one of the largest opener burn pits
as a man
a husband and a father i have felt
stripped of my dignity of my honor and
my health
imagine returning home from war only to
face a system of deny delay and deny
an employer unwilling to accommodate a
war injury resulting
from from exposure
oh i'm sorry resulting in the
involuntary end of my police career
foreclosure letters repossession notices
denial of compensation claims
as a combat veteran and first responder
my my mission to serve is etched in my
soul and my heart and i will do so until
that flag is draped over my coffin
since returning from iraq i've had over
300 medical visits and was hospitalized
immediately upon returning from iraq
the lack of health care services from va
and dod forced me to exhaust my life
savings to access care
i was diagnosed with war lung disease
and a toxic brain injury
the mental and emotional trauma is from
being shamed and treated like a
defendant having to prove that i should
have the right to keep my job after
being injured in war
my employer the department of public
safety came to my house and stripped me
of my credentials in my patrol car in
front of my family like a criminal i was
punished for serving my country
i graduated with my master's degree
while on military leave and returned to
war two weeks later why is this
important we go to war to serve our
country knowing the assert the
uncertainty of death or injury what we
don't plan on is returning home to fight
a whole new war of having to prove our
illnesses and our injuries
none of us returned from war with the
hopes of losing our careers our homes
our families
our employees and our government
continue to hide behind the curtain of
sovereign immunity
decades of advocacy begins with the
suffering the wounded and the dead whose
families are now calling on congress
demanding justice
the 9 11 world trade center first
responders were told by our government
that the air was safe they too are sick
and dying
after a decade of building systemic
momentum we have joined efforts with the
911 first responders the feel good
foundation and jon stewart to apply
their blueprint of grassroots advocacy
it's time to deliver hope to the
servicemen and women that born the
burden of america's defense
it's time we recognize these injuries as
an instrumentality of war
i also want to thank tim
jensen from grunt style for
for lending his platform uh
to to this cause right we we don't have
the reach that these uh veteran public
figures and veteran entrepreneurs such
as tim over at grunt style
have and so just the fact that he is
loaning his resources his staff uh and
his voice uh to get it done you know uh
and so
that's what we should be doing as
america is getting it done
let me just check something real quick
are you guys can you guys hear this now
with this is this
it sounds fine okay
all right good because this is boy what
a metaphor
for them uh drowning out the voices of
veterans who are trying to get health
care with some circle jerk that who
knows what they're doing over there so
just to let you know like that's what
these guys are up against theater
kabuki theater versus the real stories
and the real struggle that these guys
are going through
but they're not going to be able to
drown it out because we're not going to
let it
so so i'm glad that you guys can hear it
so
tell your story
hi i'm danielle robinson and i am now a
35 year old widow thanks to our top
military officials deciding not to
properly dispose of trash in iraq due to
inconvenience and expense
the late sergeant first class heath
robinson an army medic who enlisted
because of 9 11 was exposed to toxic
burn pits during guard duty he did while
serving as a medic in the ohio national
guard and had to stand 15 yards from a
burn pit daily for about three months of
his deployment at the camp liberty camp
victory complex after returning home the
battle for his life began 10 years later
the oncologist we saw was astonished and
said what the hell have you been exposed
to this rare form of lung cancer and
rare mucous membrane pymphogoid disease
is only due to toxic exposure
he passed this year may of 2020.
his lung autopsy results showed he also
had severe fibrosis inflammatory lung
disease
and we are still waiting for the
microscopic report from his long autopsy
at this point in time
my husband was not handed a bad genetic
hand and developed cancer this was done
to him
my husband is dead because america
knowingly poisoned its soldiers my
daughter's daddy is dead because america
poisoned its soldiers
heath fought aggressively to live for
three years which was traumatic for my
daughter and i countless hours and days
were spent in the er's doctors visits
hospitals labs radiation treatments
chemotherapy and immunotherapy
treatments and he also had multiple
surgeries and biopsies
now paint this picture in your head
a little girl walking into the bathroom
on multiple occasions finding her daddy
bent over gasping for breath and blood
is everywhere on the floor and in the
toilet because he can't stop his
nosebleeds
her running to get her mommy and asking
why is this happening i don't understand
why this is happening to daddy
also picture your loved one throwing up
in a bowl
trying to gas for breaths and you are
trying to talk him through breathing
all while holding towels up to his nose
to catch a gushing stream of blood
can you imagine trying to breathe throw
up and have a gushing nosebleed all at
the same time
you're panicking and neither of you
truly knows what to do in that moment
my daughter at the ages of four through
seven had to grow up too soon she had to
see things i wish i could make her unsee
when asking the reasons why daddy is
gone i have to be honest and i have to
tell her the truth
daddy died because he was exposed to
things no one should have to be exposed
to while fighting for our country and
our freedoms
heath was active duty at the time of his
diagnosis he went through the medical
separation process while active duty
tricare did cover his medical expenses
however once medically separated the va
began denying certain medications that
was prescribed by his oncologist we also
applied for va caregiver benefits
because i had to take leave for my
physical therapy job to handle his
around-the-clock care we were denied
this was also during a time when i had
to place a chair every 10 feet from the
path of our family room to the bathroom
upstairs in order to get him to bathe i
would have to help him crawl up the
stairs and we would have a chair on the
landing as well
each chair he had to spend about three
to five minutes in order to catch his
breath just to move another 10 feet
again my daughter had to see this and
witness this
we advocates are so appreciative to have
jon stewart and john field join our
cause but at the same time it's a
national disgrace that our war heroes
our veterans who willingly signed up to
fight for our country need celebrities
to speak out on their behalf
veterans voices don't seem to matter to
the very same people who voted to send
them off to war in the first place we
are tired of being ignored by congress
except for a handful of members i would
like to also thank congresswoman tulsi
gabbard congressman brian mast
senator sherrod brown and senator rob
portman who also introduced the sergeant
first class heath robinson burn pits
transparency act in my husband's honor
this may
one desire heath had before he died was
to testify before congress and hopes his
story would help other veterans who are
suffering and being ignored he felt
congress needs to know the full
consequences of their votes votes which
hasn't happened so far because every
congressional burn pits hearing that's
been held has been
denied
the veterans speaking
heath was a soldier who was injured on
the battlefield while deployed to a
combat zone but his toxic injuries
didn't qualify him for a purple heart
his death is not counted as a casualty
of the iraq war even though it was his
voice is now my voice the voice is just
one of many representing sick and dying
veterans
this is the war that followed our
soldiers home now i'm asking congress to
start doing their job you sent them to
iraq and afghanistan now take care of
them when they come home thank you
[Applause]
i am angelo iowa
i deployed to k2
it's a new pakistan in january of 2005.
soldiers at k2 had an incredibly dark
sense of humor as signs of radiation and
chemical hazards were all around us
my husband
was there with me and he had the similar
experiences that i did
we heard something was wrong with the
soil
no one was supposed to dig there
there were also weird
ponds of bright green liquid that
changed color they would change color to
like this burnt orange in this black
we were told that uranium was in the
water
they crammed us into a building
while they waited for shipping
containers to be installed that would be
our sleeping quarters they did not want
us living in the tents but we didn't
know why we're soldiers we're used to
sleeping in tents
every day i felt more and more drained
my knees and hips started to ache
but i thought it was the price of war
by the time i headed home from k2 i was
struggling to carry my personal gear
my chain of command knew how driven
motivated and successful i had always
been
they never yelled at me
they just wanted to know if i was okay
after returning home everything changed
food skin care hair care to name a few
everything seemed to react with my skin
and my heartbeat didn't quite feel right
i had my first dizzy spell when i was in
college
i called my husband
to tell him that i loved him and what he
meant to me
i was scared i was dying alone
would they be left with unanswered
questions about what happened to me
i told him where i was and he talked to
me and he comforted me on the phone
until it passed
one day i had to kneel at my desk to
work my feet hurt too much to stand
and my legs hurt too much to sit
that day finally broke me
many k2 veterans have been told that
it's all in our head these are warriors
good hard-working soldiers of all ranks
from every background
this summer congress was forced to
declassify military documents
many with many environmental surveys
over the last four years
finding hundreds of known tested and
documented toxic chemicals heavy metals
and radioactive material
we finally had proof
almost 20 years after the first boots
hit ground
i am the lucky one
i am alive
i have a beautiful family
i am thankful for the company that i
work for because they advocate for
veterans
they help me every way they can but i
still feel the clock ticking on my
quality of life
my heart hurts for those who have
already lost their lives and can no
longer work
my great uncle was exposed to agent
orange he became a doctor to help
himself when there was no help for him
i called him for help because he'd
always been there for me
before he died he gave me a lot of
advice
as we repeat the same cycle we must ask
when will the government do the right
thing and care for veterans with help
problems from things they were exposed
to on the battlefield
good morning everybody
when you
repeat mistakes
you tend to repeat history and that's
exactly
the situation that we find ourselves in
today
when we send our young men and women off
into conflict you have to be prepared to
take care of them
when they come back
and it's not always predictable what
situation you're going to find
yourselves in when you go into conflict
but what is predictable
is is that you're going to find yourself
in situations where our military are
exposed to hazards and exposed to
toxic
situations
when i was secretary
i was dealing with world war ii veterans
who had volunteered for our government
to be exposed to mustard gas to see what
that situation was going to be like but
since that was a classified situation
they had no documentation
and for decades they had tried to get
the help that they needed
thankfully with the working with
congress we were able to get those world
war ii veterans the benefits they
deserved
then we were dealing with the vietnam
veterans with agent orange and they too
found themselves in situations where
they didn't have
the ability to prove the association
between agent orange
and their
health issues
and again working with congress we've
been able to get them and moving towards
getting them the resolution that they so
much deserve
now of course we're dealing with our
gulf war
oef and ief veterans
and this is the situation that we find
ourselves in
last friday september 11th of all days
the national academy of sciences came
out with a report
that had some very useful
recommendations about how we have to
think differently
about collecting data
but some have misinterpreted that report
to suggest that it shows no
adverse health consequences for our gulf
war oef iaf veterans with burn pits
that's just simply wrong that's not the
correct interpretation what the national
academy of sciences said last friday is
there is no data there is no ability to
prove one way or another
about that association so what do you do
when you have veterans who are suffering
like we've heard this morning these
amazing stories these heartbreaking
stories what do you do when you don't
have any data well what we're doing
right now is making our veterans wait
without getting help
that's simply wrong it's showing we have
a backward system a system that doesn't
work that doesn't honor
our commitment that we made to these men
and women when we sent them into
conflict
so we have to change the system we have
to get it right
when there is no data available but
there's a plausible explanation and
veterans are suffering we have to give
veterans the doubt we have to give them
the benefit of doubt and that means we
have to change our system to honor that
commitment we gave to them and that's
why we need to work with congress
to be able to
have them
use their oversight abilities to get
this situation fixed for our veterans
thank you
[Applause]
you know about 20 minutes ago
i was talking to the group
i said calm down
this is a this is a marathon
we're all in this together
then i heard that crap behind me
and man my blood pressure's right here
right here
and i listened and he said
america's worth fighting for
then they clapped
but not one person
on those steps
stopped
to talk to any of these heroes behind me
not one person stopped
and said thank you for your service are
you okay
how can i help
you just said america's worth fighting
for what's up
are you kidding
me this is embarrassing
so we come here today
for 15 years this man
took an issue that was in the shadows
and put sunlight on it
now we're asking him again
to take an issue
that's been in the shadows
and put sunlight on it
to let the american people know
that good ordinary people who do
extraordinary things to keep us safe 24
7 are sick and dying
what have we become
when we stop a legislative process and
we tweet all day
when nothing gets done anymore
this is embarrassing oh we're the
greatest country in the world
i'm shocked i'm appalled and i'm
repulsed by what i'm listening to right
now behind me
these men and women deserve better
the 911 community deserved better
the american people i get it we're all
going to a lot right now pandemic social
uprising election
but when do we stop caring
about life
about human beings
if you're all right with that
then we're not friends thank you
so
before we
you know we're hearing the stories now
and uh
it's heartbreaking and and we haven't
had any change i want to make one thing
clear like let's
let's be
honest about what's going to happen now
so we're going to go to congress and
we're going to try and put every
congressperson senator and
representative on record
if they're okay with this and they're
all going to say the same thing we don't
have the science
so i would challenge each one of these
congress people to go back to their
district and say
we're going to dig a acre pit and we're
going to take all the garbage hazardous
materials and everything else from this
town and we're going to pour jet fuel on
it and we're going to light it in the
center of the town
and when your constituents come to you
and say what's with this thick black
acrid smoke
just say i think it's fine
we don't have the science particularly
they're holding these veterans to a bar
that nobody can meet we know smoking
causes lung cancer
but if you have lung cancer you can't
actually prove that it was the smoke and
that's the bar that they're holding
these veterans to
and it's unacceptable and the truth is
it's not about science it's about money
they don't want to do this for these
veterans
because
they think it's too expensive we always
have money for war we never have money
for the war fighter
and it's unacceptable we support the
troops until the troops need support
and then we bury it
so i'm going to tell you something that
is the optimism in this that's the
sunlight in this and that is
this is an eminently fixable problem
it's simple
and the money already exists in the
system
it doesn't involve a new funding
initiative that taxpayers have to pay
for the money to help these veterans
is in the system and i'll give you i'll
give you off the top of my head four
ways to do it
the pentagon has an 800 billion dollar
budget along with an 80 billion dollar
oco fund overseas contingency operations
fund that's unaccountable
take
five percent
of the oco and we've got it
400 billion dollars of the pentagon
budget goes to defense contractors
people that profit off of sending our
men and women to war
yet they have no accountability for the
consequences of that two percent tax on
war profiteers and we have the money
the f-35
is gonna cost 1.4 trillion dollars and
nobody thinks it's going to be anything
the a-10 already takes care of
everything that could possibly take care
of the f-35 is going to be useless
they're going to make 2 400 of them for
1.4 trillion dollars just make 2 000 of
them
and we have the money
this is it's [ __ ] the money is
already in the system we're just not
allocating it to the right
people
how is it that we have
the pentagon wouldn't even do an audit
1990 they made it illegal to not audit
every department the pentagon never
complied until a couple of years ago
they failed their audit
and the penalty for failure
was an enormous increase in their budget
meanwhile each soldier that comes home
is put on trial
for their health care
because if the va and the pentagon can
make it so that their health condition
is not a part of their service they
don't have to pay any money
that's what this is about
it's easily fixable it's eminently
solvable the money is already in the
system please
please talk to each one of these
individuals and get their stories please
do not allow
congress people to duck this issue we
have the money
it's there
so uh uh
senator gillibrand please
john and john are exactly right the
money is there
they're afraid of spending money they
refuse to spend money they don't want to
spend money they never have
but because of this effort they will
i want to thank john field and jon
stewart for dedicating themselves to
these veterans in the same exact way you
dedicated yourselves to the 911 first
responders your service and your
advocacy mean the world to these
families and i just want to thank you
for doing that
i want to thank secretary shulkin for
being here to lend your voice to this
issue
you've seen it you've lived it you know
how vital it is that we fight for this
money and this ability for families to
get the health care they need and i want
to thank congressman ruiz for working
with me on this solution
i also want to recognize the very brave
families and the women that just spoke
before us
their stories are truly heartbreaking
as a mother i can't imagine my daughter
seeing
what your daughter saw
i can't imagine the spouses here that
have lived it and those who have watched
their husbands live it
it's a crippling feeling to not be able
to protect the ones you love
i'm especially grateful to all of our
veterans and military families here who
not only have served our country but who
continue
to serve their fellow men and women in
uniform by fighting for them
fighting for the health care that they
are owed and that they deserve
the stories that have been shared here
today
should be enough
to move anyone to act
that more than three million service
members
could have stories like theirs from
exposure to toxic fumes of burn pits is
a moral outrage
it's also a looming health crisis that
must be addressed
burn pits which are so dangerous that
they are outlawed on american soil
were used on bases around the world
veterans lived and breathed in a toxic
cocktail of dust smoke and debris now
many are sick and dying from lung
disease cancers and respiratory
illnesses
and as we've heard
burn pits were not the only source of
these exposures to dangerous toxins
of service members were stationed at k2
air base that once held soviet chemical
weapons
many now suffer from rare cancers and
other ailments
when these veterans go to the va for
care the va says they have to show
medical evidence of a disease or
disability evidence of their physical
presence near a specific exposure site
and evidence of the link between illness
and exposure
then once these veterans have jumped
through all of those hoops the va has
said as john said the science isn't
there
that is a denial of their responsibility
the va continues to claim there's not
enough evidence that these ailments are
service connected but we do have
evidence
we know what was burned we know what was
in the soil we know that the toxic fumes
and environmental conditions were so
hazardous that the dod changed the rules
for burning and switched to incinerators
in many places
and we have seen the ailments of our 9
11 responders and vietnam veterans who
have developed exposures from some of
the exact same toxins
these men and women many of whom are
fighting for their lives should not have
to fight the va for the care that is
linked to their service
for the va to drag its feet
is it outrage
many of our veterans have no time to
spare
this is the same battle vietnam veterans
had to bring to fight for coverage
because of agent orange
physically fit men and women who were
exposed to toxic chemicals returned from
war came down with rare cancers and
other ailments and were told to wait
to wait for the science
congress overrode the va in 1991 and
gave veterans vietnam veterans the
presumptive coverage for all these
ailments we have to do the same for the
veterans of the war on terror
our bill would do exactly that
the presumptive benefits for war
fighters exposed to burn pits and other
toxins act will remove the burden of
proof
it will remove that burden from our
veterans by establishing a presumptive
service connection for veterans exposed
to burn pits and other toxins and
streamline the process so they can get
the benefits they have already earned
from the va
no more forcing veterans to beg the dod
for paperwork to prove their exposure to
spend late nights researching the links
between lung cancer lung scarring and
toxic smoke from these burn pits or try
to get notes from a private doctor
trying to convince the va that this
disease could only be caused by toxic
environmental exposure
all that service members would have to
submit to receive care is evidence of
deployment to one of the 34 countries
named in the bill or receipt of a
service of metal associated with the
global war on terror and the gulf war
to put it simply the bill says that if
you were there you are covered plain and
simple
this bill applies
common sense and common decency
to a very broken process
and i am fighting alongside these
families these service members and these
advocates
i hope that my colleagues on both sides
of the aisle have heard their voices i
hope they understand what is at stake
here and i hope that they will stand
with every service member who put their
lives on the line for this country
that's the least they can do
[Applause]
good morning i'm congressman raul ruiz
and i represent california's 36th
congressional district
i'm also an emergency medicine physician
public health expert and founder and
co-chair of the congressional bipartisan
burn pits caucus
first i want to thank danielle
angela and all the veterans and their
families with us
thank you for your service
to our nation and thank you for your
strength
in telling your stories
you are the reason why we're here today
i'd also like to thank jon stewart and
john phil for your advocacy and
commitment to the cause
rosie torres for your incredible work
and whom i've had the honor to have in
my district back in 2018 uh educating
the veterans in my district about burn
pits at my veterans university
i'd like to thank secretary shulkin for
your years of service and for joining us
here today and of course senator
gillibrand for your partnership in this
fight
i stand before you today because of the
bravery and sacrifice of jennifer kepner
a constituent of mine who was exposed to
burn pits during her service at balad
air force base in iraq
jennifer kepner was 39 years old a
mother of two
who served our nation as an air force
medic
she was one of the most inspiring and
brave people i have ever met
when i met jennifer
we sat at her kitchen table
and let me tell you it was one of the
most impactful kitchen table
conversation i've had in my life
and she told me about her life about her
service about her husband ben kepner and
their two young children ada and wyatt
whom she loved dearly
and she told me about her military
service in balad iraq where she was
exposed to one of the largest burn pits
up to 10 acres
where they burned batteries jet fuel
medical waste and much much more
releasing large plumes of black smoke
and causing her and her fellow soldiers
to inhale toxic chemicals carcinogens
and particulate matter
when we spoke jennifer was battling
pancreatic cancer
a diagnosis her doctor linked to her
exposure to burn pits during her service
overseas
by the time i met jennifer she had only
months to live
and jennifer spent her final days as a
leading voice for her fellow veterans
exposed to burn pits even in the midst
of her own
unimaginable suffering
i was at her bedside with her family
when she died on october 18 2017
and through it all
jennifer had only two requests
only two dying requests dying wishes one
to make sure
her family was taken care of
and two to make sure that other veterans
are protected and their families from
the pain and suffering that she
experienced not only from burn pits but
also from her difficult experience
navigating the va after being denied
it is for jennifer
it is for leroy rosie's husband for
heath danielle's husband for angela and
her husband and many others that we
fight to fulfill jennifer's wishes
fueled by stories like jennifer and
countless others i've developed a
comprehensive four-pronged public health
approach to address burn pits
by one ending the use of burn pits once
and for all two educating doctors and
veterans on the health effects of burn
pit exposure to identify risks and early
symptoms three taking care of our
veterans and their families with medical
care and disability benefits and four
continuing the needed research to fully
understand the scope of danger
associated with burn pit and other toxic
exposures
stories like jennifer
danielle's
and countless other veterans have been
my inspiration for legislation such as
the jennifer kepner hope act
and they are the reason why i created
the bipartisan bicameral congressional
burn pits caucus in 2018.
service members are returning home from
the battlefield only to become delayed
casualties of war
dying years later from lung diseases
cancers respiratory illnesses autoimmune
diseases caused by their exposure to
burn pits and other toxins drawing
parallels with agent orange and 911
exposures in fact jennifer told me that
this indeed is the agent orange of our
generation
the dod and the va must acknowledge the
lethal dangers of this self-inflicted
crisis and address the suffering of
exposed veterans look
i'm an emergency medicine physician and
public health expert and in public
health and in medicine
it is practice that if there is a high
enough suspicion of a harm that causes a
severe enough
consequence
then we need to act on that suspicion
we have evidence that give us a high
enough suspicion carcinogens on the dust
metals in lung biopsies that have been
proven
and it is a severe enough consequence
men and women dying left and right in
their young healthy years with no other
risk factors are dying from cancers lung
diseases and other severe illnesses
so we need to remove the harm and treat
the person
our veterans cannot afford
to wait decades for that perfect 20-year
longitudinal double cohort study like
they were forced to with agent orange
people are dying
and that's why we're here today to
ensure the va and dod cannot neglect
this dod self-inflicted wound
any longer
this is about taking care of our heroes
in uniform and saving veterans lives
the presumptive benefits for war
fighters exposed to burn pits and other
toxins act of 2020 would do just that
by establishing the presumption of
service connection necessary for
veterans who develop respiratory
diseases and cancers from toxic exposure
and
the bill would direct the secretary of
the va to work with the national
academies
to study a link between toxic exposures
and additional
diseases so today we're closer than ever
to realizing jennifer's vision of
getting veterans the health care they've
earned and deserve closer than ever to
seeing the fulfillment of leroy and
rosie's and heath and danielle's and
angela's dream of a just society that
really respects those war fighters as
jon stewart says when they come home we
give them the respect that they're due
and the appreciation that they do by
taking care of them when they get
illness from burn pit and other toxic
exposures but better than that let's
just end those exposures to begin with
[Applause]
so i look forward
to continuing our work to get this bill
signed into law
and taking care of our heroes and once
again
thank you jon stewart
john phil rosie torres secretary shulkin
senator gillibrand danielle angina and
all the veterans that are here today
i will now turn it back over to jon
stewart for questions
thank you and remember this is just the
beginning this is you know none of us
have any illusions
that today changes anything but today we
plant a flag
and we say
we're coming back here and we're going
to
exhibit the relentlessness that these
war fighters
man congress has no idea the resilience
of these individuals and
we're going to come back here i want to
thank all the veterans organizations all
the way back to the uh vietnam veterans
on whose shoulders
this
project stands on who've had to fight
for theirs and vietnam veterans are
still fighting
for their benefits man
america is like four wars behind
when it comes to caring for their
veterans
and the delaying tactics and just
waiting for people to be sick and die
is not
a mantle worthy of a country like ours
and we can't continue to do it so
we're going to activate the american
legion and we're going to activate the
iava and we're going to activate the
wounded warrior project and we're going
to activate the vietnam
veterans of america and we're going to
fill this space
with veterans and victims and advocates
until those congress people that you saw
walk by here
with not a care in the world
about what these families have gone
through
until they're forced to face it
and we need your help so please i'm
begging of you interview the individuals
here get their stories
don't let this die
and if there are any questions everybody
would be happy to answer them
yes ma'am um
joseph r biden jr lost his uh son bo
biden also joe biden to cancer he was
also an iraq survivor
do you think he would be on board with
this cause have you talked to him about
it what would that support mean
i mean i i look i can't imagine that
anybody isn't on board with this cause
this is this is the lowest hanging
legislative fruit you could possibly
pick
so you shouldn't have to have a family
member
die of a toxic exposure
to be able to understand
the pain and difficulty and tenacity
that these families have had to
undergo on their own
we we make them advocate on their own
they have to be their own lawyer doctor
scientist
when they leave
the army
the the name whatever their services
they become
said adrift
so and senator you had something yeah so
i saw
vice president biden at the 9 11
memorial uh on i guess that was friday
and um
i told him that we were working on this
build together
with a bunch of service members and
survivors and
he was really grateful and
i don't want to repeat his words because
they weren't for publication but i can
tell you
he is
very much moved by this effort he is
grateful for this effort and when he is
president uh he will support this effort
i'm quite certain
yeah please can i say one thing real
quick yeah yeah please
so i did the research and bill biden's
son or i mean joe biden some bow was
actually deployed to the same
bases as heath about the same time so
camp bond steel and kosovo they were
both deployed about the same time and
camp victory in iraq
yeah i spoke to vice president joe biden
years ago about this issue when we
formed the burn pits caucus and he was
keenly aware of the association of burn
pits and the potential of of it being
the cause for bo biden's brain cancer
in addition to those bases he was also
deployed in balad uh where jennifer
kepner was was deployed and so i i
believe that we will have a champion as
well with uh with with vice president
joe biden uh and
and with a new administration with
somebody who has was personally touched
by the consequences of being exposed to
burn pits
i think i speak for everybody i think i
speak for everybody when i say um
we don't care who the president is
um previous administrations
have failed us whether you're in the 911
community in the veteran community
john and i sat on joe biden's cancer
moonshot task force
um but we're here today trying to get a
bill passed for veterans so
it doesn't matter who's president
doesn't matter who's in control of the
house or the senate
whoever gets in our way and opposes us
you guys saw what we did to congress for
15 years we're going to punch him in the
mouth
any other uh questions for
hi tara kopp with mcclatchy uh this
question is both for you john and for
senator gillibrand for years the k2
veterans haven't even been able to go to
the burn pit registry to get help
they've been invisible they haven't been
because
of just the burning pit registry only
including iraq and afghanistan
right
this effort
this changes that and please understand
like the burn pit registry is a joke
like that's just a way for them to kick
this thing down the road
rosie has registered more people in the
burn pit registry for herself as far as
the va is concerned
there's only ten thousand veterans
in the burn pit registry
that have made claims and eight thousand
of those veterans were denied
this is a problem
for hundreds of thousands of veterans
what they did with the registry is a
joke they tried to do the same thing
with the 911 first responders it's a
tactic this is about
money
and not wanting to spend the money
to care for veterans that our government
poisoned i can't make it more stark than
that
it's nonsense
yes please
so on that point of the k2 veterans um
not only have the k2 veterans not been
had the opportunity to self-register um
but the va has also uh declined to
accept any of these fallen heroes
families to submit a death entry so not
only are they not you know allowing the
k2 but they're not tracking mortality uh
so what we've done through with very
minimal selling t-shirts and whatever
we have a poster here of our registry of
people in every congressional district
some of those people are these families
standing here behind me um and so john's
right like it'll change a lot of things
for a lot of population affected
so the purpose of this bill is to
exactly
exactly answer that question
we have a whole host of countries that
are covered
any deployment for the war on terror is
covered and
we believe there's probably 3.5 million
veterans who are exposed so it's a huge
number
right now
in terms of airborne hazards and open
burn pit registry that website has about
212 000 veterans already registered
between 2014 and
august 2020 so we have a long way to go
and people need to know that they are
covered and that these diseases will
need to be treated we also
want to create the ability to have
expertise in these areas because what we
found in the 911 health bill is that a
general practitioner doesn't know what
these diseases are related to and then
don't know how to treat them properly so
what we need to do is develop an area of
expertise for physicians to know this is
what happens when you are exposed to a
burn pit so they can get the best
treatment and save their lives because a
regular doctor won't know and that's why
the
specialty has to be developed just as we
did for the 911 survivors and the 911
individuals who were exposed and got
diseased
and i hope you're all catching the
catch-22 here
which is that dod and va don't collect
the proper data
and then they put out a study saying we
can't help you we don't have enough data
and you have to wait for us to get the
data that we never collected
pretty convenient
and and a lot of nonsense and i just
remembered uh there was an internal
pentagon audit 125 million dollars of
waste fought and abuse could be saved
over five years so guess what just from
that we have the money yes sir the uh
during the vcf fight the first
responders and the survivor community
delilah nordstroms the john fields they
were forced to make hundreds of trips to
capitol hill over well more than a
decade i'm curious from your perspective
what are your biggest learned lessons as
an advocate to help prevent the same
path forward for these families so that
they're not also here hundreds of times
knocking on doors
i i just don't know i mean john phil can
speak to that more than i can the only
thing that i can say is
injustice thrives in the dark
and so
the strategy for them whether it be from
ignorance or malevolence or
incompetence or laziness
is to keep this in the dark
and and our job is to force this into
the light
and to make everybody face
these brave individuals
and explain to them
why the most obvious fixes can't be
accomplished by a government that
purports to support its troops over all
else
it's simple yes sir
on behalf of the veterans i represented
connectingvets.com
um
and you know to the congressional
officials um what's something we can
actually do everybody
says get the bill passed but for for my
fellow veterans as you've mentioned
without a hundred trips to the hill
do you guys hear our tweets because i
tweeted a hell of a lot of congress
people on the veterans affairs committee
and i don't i mean they they don't they
don't should i do to get this so so
here's what we're doing
it's not that this issue hasn't had
attention or effort right
but it's got to be concerted
and it has to have a central locus
and it has to be done
with a certain focus and and uh
intention
so
what you can do is we're going to create
moments
where we activate
our entire population
because those are we have to create uh
enough noise
to get their attention because you see
they they just walk they just walk by
that was 50 minutes of nonsense
of
self-congratulatory nonsense
while real people facing real
consequence
stand here waiting for
help so
in those moments what what i would say
to you is and and anybody out there
who's connected to a an organization
that has stake in this
follow rosie
uh follow grunts follow all these groups
we're going to create a time
where we can activate activate everyone
in a concerted moment
to get their attention
and in that moment we're going to need
all of you
can i just
let me take you guys down memory lane
in 2010 we were that little engine that
could we got lucky we got a bill passed
2015 we were that big engine that did
and we got a bill passed last year you
guys all know we got a bill passed
so there's 433 out of 435 congressional
districts represented at ground zero
during the 10-month cleanup
so while we had the voice of jon stewart
and the media behind us
we also had the american people
and we had 9 11 responders and
volunteers in every state and we had
them do local interviews then we had
them go to their congressional offices
so when we deploy
everybody this time
we're going to be that much bigger
and that much stronger and we're going
to go to congressional districts
throughout the whole country not one
will be left
then we're going to have all of these
soldiers affected by the burn pits their
families their widows
they're going to do interviews in local
tv stations radio stations print
and we are going to suffocate
a body of work
a dysfunctional
body of work no offense to you two you
guys
and we're going to make their lights
miserable
we're going to put our foot on their
neck
and we're not going to allow them to
come up to breathe
if they get on board
we're going to challenge them to get
their colleagues on board
so today
like john said we're planting the uh the
flag
now we're here to let you know we're in
the mood for a fight if it has to go
that way
we come in peace but we're ready to
fight
and we're fighting
for human life
we're challenging the humanity
of members of congress
because before you a republican or a
democrat
you're supposed to be an american and
before you're an american
you're supposed to be a human being
and if you don't get that
then you don't belong
in office in the first place
so
today
starts what is going to be a marathon
john stewart really has nothing to do
last time i checked he's
he's
he's feeding goats and pigs on his farm
i'm a very busy and popular man but
here's the thing
john's responsibility
is 10 times larger now than it was to us
in the 911 community
you know
when we held our last press conference
after the bill got passed in the senate
john said he would follow me anywhere
i held him to that now
and now i will follow john anywhere
and while i'm never ever ever
married
or
loyal to an institution
i am now married and loyal to these
people behind me and the thousands that
can't be here today
i will die
for these people
i will give
my last kidney for these people
and i will
punch a member of congress in the mouth
for these people
yes no no you guys stop sugarcoating and
stop playing nice
for years we played nice
for years we played by their rules
and every time we played by their rules
they made up a new set of rules
until we outworked them until we
outbought them until we out hustled them
until we got legislation passed not once
not twice not three times not four times
but five times in dc five five times we
are 13 for 13 now and getting
legislation passed and with jon stewart
and these ass kicking warriors i like
our odds
uh hello everybody my name is tim jensen
chief strategy officer at grunt style
couldn't be more proud to be part of
this project and what we're trying to
accomplish here
if you remember seven years ago during
sequestration 2013
they had shut down all the national
monuments here in washington dc the
power that the veteran community has is
that we can activate as fast as possible
because that's what we do we know this
we know this game
right in 2013 we brought tens of
thousands of veterans down here and we
brought
up or we opened every one of these
monuments carried those uh those guard
rails all the way down pennsylvania
avenue and threw them into the white
house lawn we circled the white house
and we let them know
this was not acceptable for our
community these deaths that are
happening in this community is
unacceptable we didn't go to war to come
home to die by something that our
government did to us
i lost my best friend my co my exo many
of my my friends and my family i have
cancer because of this and they're dying
i'm not going to stand for it any longer
i'm going to use this platform that
grunt style has built over the years to
connect with every veteran in this
country i'm going to create heat maps of
every legislator
representative and their constituents
and i'm going to activate them all i'm
going to get them to send every one of
these legislators a letter saying we
demand you to act now and for all those
veterans that are up on the hill that
are doing nothing that passed nothing
i'm telling you this you
as john said john feel we're coming and
we're gonna fight we know what fight
looks like and it's not over
the the at the end of the day it remains
the same we are in the fight for our
lives
and i'm not going to die
on my own soil because of what something
the government did to me or any one of
my brothers and sisters anymore
as they walked by could you could you
tell us what was said or what the spirit
of that uh conversation was well you
know they're up on the the steps of the
of the capitol here uh talking whatever
it is about well you know let's
america's worth fighting for and you're
absolutely right america is worth
fighting for but you know these are the
men and women that are actually doing
the fighting
at the end of the day when when uh you
know politics fail what happens it's the
united states military that has to go
and clean up the work and every time it
goes back
decades centuries these veterans are
left holding the bag
and every one of them you saw they
walked by they looked at us and they
kept walking and they shook their heads
like we're the we're the scum no it's
over mark my words guys
it's over
thank you everybody for coming
appreciate you
thank you so much thank you so much
this
is myself